[Music]
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation if we are not covering the
trolls franchise we are watching a
horror movie oh yeah Roxy strier welcome
back I think we are the First new
Channel movie I mean new Channel movie
and here I was thinking I was going to
make the intro more efficient than you
how are you how are you how are you just
answer the question am I I am stay
golden pony boy that what's that from
Outsiders yes I read it I didn't see it
but it was in the book I read literate
oh you're a genius all right well today
we are watching orphan do you have an
orphan joke you got jokes about orphans
yeah well I'm part of the DPC and so are
you which is the dead parent Club but we
do have one M but they're the president
of the club we're only vice president
yeah how are you Greg this is great 2024
kickoff video I'm really excited if we
can do the DPC right at the top of this
hey they should leave a like on the
video shouldn't they Roxy especially if
they're DPC you got to support other DPC
members yeah dpc's in the comments
subscribe click the notification B get
notified when Roxy has another video up
on this channel she's going to be doing
so many now too many also thank you to
prepper for helping us edit down these
highlights you guys Rock full length
watch La where you s it with your own
copy of Orphan as Avil for super sex
rejects over at our patreon page and
over there John I cover several things
exclusively with highlights and watch
Longs included you ready to get the fear
on you didn't need notes at all no I
didn't need notes at all I've been doing
this forever
you knew it all in the nogin that's all
in the Noggin you're very good at this
Greg oh I appreciate it thanks orphan
has no successors success has no orphan
failure is an orphan but success has
many parents that's the quote that I've
been trying to think of for the last two
minutes let's do
it we haven't watched a movie together
in a long time Roxy yeah I pissed you
off did I pee in your
cereal I missed
[Laughter]
[Music]
you hang on okay ver for me gu I do know
her name yes let's go let's go you got
one doing so I know him but I don't know
his name I call him sleepy eyes his name
is Peter sarsgard oh I could have gotten
that by the end of the movie in the
credits I'll be right up yeah okay this
looks like a
dream
something tells me based off the title
of this movie that this pregnancy is not
going to go yeah but how's it going to
kill the dad what the hell what
conclusion did you jump to Orphan maybe
they
adopt well the child's going to be born
but then it's going to be born an orphan
it kills the mom and somehow the dad
dies I don't think that's what's going
to happen they're the stars of this
movie oh yeah that's a good
point
just relax now everything's going to be
okay oh it is a dream I'm so sorry for
your loss what your baby's dead no it's
not dead it's alive what a way to say
that the lights
creepy oh the crunch sound oh Greg nope
NOP this is a dark ass
opening he's filming okay honey what are
you doing feel some
tugging
this is the opening of the movie
congratulations Mrs Coleman it's a
girl okay okay so the horrors I'm
assuming she lost a baby and it's the
traumas of that no I told you her and
Peter die in the first five minutes yeah
they killed off the main characters
yep I don't know people also have weird
dreams when they are pregnant so maybe
this is a premonition of source just a
fear of what's to come possibly oh no
lost the baby yeah all of your guesses
have been spot on today and mine have
also been equally spot
on I love the concrete style bathroom I
know as much as they're going through
some depressing ass [__] and living the
good life financially design strong yeah
money doesn't solve all problems but
many n it can certain mask some though
that's for sure of your emotions is your
body and mind's way of dealing with the
stress and grief of what happened oh
Margo marale I love her you know that
name right away well she was an
Americans which was one of my favorite
shows love it we seeing kids for the
first time this weekend maybe I'm just
not ready to adopt yet I drove by the
wine shop on the way home the other
night you think she's sober but you
didn't go in mm- the key to me I think
she's lying is not that you had the urge
but that you resisted it trust me you
wouldn't have made it through the home
study if you weren't ready I think she
will eventually relapse it's a better
guess at the all's lost moment of this
movie or midpoint based off of Hollywood
structures just it felt like there was
more behind her answer and she said M it
felt like mhm now I already kind of see
the character Arc here
is this a niece no she has two kids
before the one that she lost that's
[Music]
right oh oh oh
oh look like there was someone in the
reflection did you see that oh yeah I
forgot the kid was back
there I like is there a ghost child in
that car it was legit 15 seconds before
before that we met that are you good I
was just SE in the moment
yeah I was honestly thinking about like
look at this home it's gorgeous way to
hide from your proms I was thinking
about like how great vera for Mega is at
pling depressed Disturbed
woman I'm always impressed with any
movie that has Margot Martin Dale in it
though because then you know that you're
you really give a crap about the caliber
of
[Music]
actor
very good
[Laughter]
[Music]
Roxy Max stop throwing I'm
working no honey I'm a take a break for
a little while okay cuz mommy's trying
to
play so she had a miscarriage a child
who's hearing
impaired does this CH first child have
anything sorry practice went a little
late it's all right bully
syndrome give me Daniel
fine directionally looked like it was
going fors the car it wasn't trying to
see if there's any horror details that
we going to come back around anytime
later cuz I do is like very specific
close-ups on things she's wearing cleer
implants so maybe she has some of her
hearing when it's in
[Music]
interesting to go into the daughter's
perspective on this scene well as she
took them out
[Music]
yeah okay so a that's a sweet
story
that's a big reaction for a kid about
[Music]
that hard like how do you explain that
to your kids anybody who has a stillborn
or a
miscarriage usually the a I've heard the
angel approach done before I knew
someone a family who had that once and
it was actually a very similar type of
way to translate the
[Music]
story
very quick way to get us invested in
these characters thinking the same thing
because it start off like so
aggressively horror and then I'm like oh
now I'm just invested in the drama of
these guys the emotionality not invested
in the dad yet though where you at
homie tell you the truth not a big fan
of him isn't I really
yeah B see I'll be open man I really
like this bathroom sorry sorry sorry
sorry love a good mirror jump scare I'm
very excited I'm happy I get nervous I'm
really scared is she pregnant again no
they're going to adopt oh that's what
she's scared about last time I felt all
of this was right before I lost the baby
I just don't want you to feel like we
have to go through with this for my sake
good call Greg yeah also they said it in
the therapy session no yeah yeah I
remember that it's the way she was
looking the mirror I don't know
I'm going to take the love that we felt
for Jessica and I want to give it to
somebody who really needs it you sure
yes it's cool that they're having the
conversation of you know like the grief
of losing a child or miscarriage but
then also are we worthy enough to adopt
like I think they're very human
questions to be asking I'm not judging
the characters or something like that
I'm just saying that these are
conversations that I've heard in real
life of other people have done it and
I've adopted for a reason like this
get thee to a
nunery okay so they're all orphans here
it's an orphan the name of the movie
which is why Greg this is usually you
get orphans from an
orphanage oh my God that is creepy you
creepy little shits so so hard to figure
out who you're picking like that's got
to be torturous oh my God no it's not no
problem go with the whitest one I have
five adopted cousins and every time I'm
like how did you know who whitest one
best looking one good teeth you want to
look at teeth okay I'm sure they got a
future ahead based off their looks
alone hello oh hi are all these
paintings yours yes oh no I'm very upset
right now upset yeah that he's being
lured into doing this no I just don't
know what to make of this and like you
don't want to get close to somebody my
name is Esther what's yours hi Esther
John nice to meet you cuz like Esther
knows what's happening right now this is
so sad where'd you get the idea for this
one my paintings always tell story this
one's about the sad mother lion who
can't find her cops she's smiling oh
Esther's smart this is one worth
adopting I hope she finds them she will
look does she have an accent yeah what
is it French they were lost in the
jungle and they were so scared because
they didn't have a mother or father just
when they thought they'd be alone
forever they found their mother asleep
under this
tree oh God okay this is es
hello oh no yep yeah don't don't adopt
that kid she painted all these really
yeah these are fantastic that's great
there's such a sense of wonder around
Esther and then that nun's like don't
the do it man just had lots of time to
practice I guess it's really boring here
hey if you're so bored why aren't you
down at the party I've never really seen
the point of it nobody's ever talked to
me before why why I guess I'm Different
there's nothing wrong with being
different you know a you're going to
regret those words I think people should
always try to take the bad things that
happen to them in their lives and turn
them into something good don't you
absolutely that's a great Outlook
Outlook and I feel like there's
consequences awaiting she's originally
from Russia but it's amazing how strong
her Russ she's only been in the country
a few years I have a cousin adopted from
Russia the family that brought her to
America died in a house fire a fire did
Esther Start the Fire this is an
extraordinary little girl she's very
bright she's very mature for her age
it's a bit of a princess actually she
wears those ribbons on her wrists and
her neck all the time oh no the only
time we've ever had trouble with her is
when we've tried to take them off uh
it's a you ever heard the story they
take it off the head goes the green
ribbon with the head did you you didn't
read that as a kid oh it's like the
scariest I don't think that's what's
going to hen but sure that's be awesome
she wear this ribbon around her neck and
she wouldn't let anybody take it off and
finally when they did her head fell off
that's like a real horror it's a real
Horror Story book that kids read I read
it might have called Red Ribbon or green
ribbon was it your adopted Russian
cousin who read this to call me if you
need anything than bye thank you Esther
is such a non little kid name like you
think of like an old woman yeah yeah
she's got old soul to her she paints
maybe there's something there this feels
like an older horror movie to me in a
good way where it's like taking its time
it's doing the character buildup but
nowadays I feel like they're like 90
minutes tight dread things like this
just feels like a family drama right
now te Ag and Ma is like this oh yeah
she's yeah got to communicate with the
fan bam it's got to be so
scary hello Max my name is Esther she's
been practicing the whole
way a she's so adorable so cute i' like
to introduce you to Grandma Barbara it's
a pleasure to meet
you that's precious it's a pleasure to
meet you oh little boy you're going to
get hurt or maybe he tortures her we
don't know oh you have a piano yeah
she's so s
sophisticated Greg I'm like preemptively
gutted right now do you like it it's
perfect good we're having two very
different responses I'm like I don't
trust this little girl and you're like I
feel terrible for this little girl how
do you say thank you thank you I hope
the Twisted she's just a Russian spy
she's a kid Greg yeah they train them
young wow look at
that what like you're treating her like
she's
Megan you got to be
prepared thank
you come on my soul's going to end hurry
look wow
cool oh no he's already jealous oh she
knows exactly what she's doing
infiltrate Esther Greg her whole family
died in a fire and I wonder why okay but
say she did Start the Fire as a kid you
her Didn't Start the
Fire how's she doing Kate Esther's
fitting right in I met Maxine she's
playing by the pond like nothing ever
happened she doesn't remember anything
does she no she's fine that's where the
miscarriage was what are your plans you
know probably get Esther settled and uh
and go back to teaching that's a pet
peeve of mine I don't like when people
eat cake like that I was just thinking
how great that cake
looks that's a very good job yeah well I
didn't quit cuz I wanted to you had to
have your Moment of clarity that is an
AA term and I didn't go to AA I just
stopped drinking same difference
judgmental I don't know what your
opinion is of Vera Faro but I think she
is a phenomenal actress yeah she's
incredible she's really really good the
amount of nuances she can do in one
scene y she's really really good so
super super solid so with you Greg every
scene every like
moment yeah it doesn't help that she's
so ugly though you know what I mean like
God damn that is a challenge it is a
real she's had to overcome that part of
her
career
whoa when did this movie get
great what the [__] is happening with
little Esther's going to come in this is
not the right timing eser go in there
Esther ruined this for him oh no Oh no
you're mad at Esther because she's about
to ruin a hey watch your words I already
have to work around this footage that's
why I said it like that yeah you don't
think it's still going to what do you
want me to call it a bee
sure oh
no oh yeah how how you feel about Esther
right now sad for
her yeah we're scared of the lightning
oh come in I want to sleep next to Daddy
she's a manipulative old
soul oh yeah you want to make sure
you're color up against your wife right
now maybe she was
scared
es eser she's working her way up to be
number one child she was putting the
ribbon on but we didn't see the front
you saw and her head her head was still
on yeah yeah but I'm just saying she
very clearly has scars or something
somebody cut her or something sweetheart
this isn't really a school dress but I
like it don't you think it's pretty she
is so good at being sweet though little
eser you're afraid the other children
will laugh at me aren't you I thought
you said there wasn't anything wrong
with being different there isn't depends
on what that different is and if I agree
with it have
fun you're okay Roxy I I I'm aching
inside Greg let it out it's why we react
to show how we
feel okay this is our new student her
name is Esther Coleman and I'd like you
all to make her feel very welcome today
nobody's going to make her feel welcome
little B peep text me she wants her
outfit back it's time to strangle that
little girl Esther can take a seat okay
if everybody could turn to page
27 like why didn't the teacher say
anything like in these movies all the
time they hear the insults and they're
like everybody take a seat how about
like [__] go to the principal office
that was mean cuz movie needs to happen
and Esther needs to murder you don't
play near the water you know that come
on get out her biggest fear is losing
her
children
who Craig you ever gotone
paintballing I have actually
yeah see this kid freaks me out more
don't do it kid don't do it I don't like
him you do this I I wish death upon you
right
away and uh Esther going to murder you
bad YouTube that kid is probably a grown
adult now I can say that about him you
wished death upon Him Greg he deserves
to die you want him unived he just
murdered a bird for his own Amusement
let's see what Esther has to say about
this just a paintball I didn't think
it'd hurt him oh my God Esther's going
to finish the
job put him out of his
misery
aser put it out of its misery you're
Aster it's in pain yeah and it's your
responsibility that's true if you walk
away now it'll starve to death is that's
what you want not doing it
that is so violent it's in heaven
now I don't think Esther believes in
heaven she's been put through the ringer
she's had a lot of her life Greg it's
okay to be different y okay call me if
you need anything I agree no I'm on
Esther's side on this one damn that was
cold you are on Esther's side I mean she
had to put the bird out of the misery oh
you agree okay okay yeah just but the
way the manner in which she did
it look at that knob what's about to
happened Esther good creepy string
music what are you doing I always lock
the door no we don't lock doors in this
house what if someone comes in and sees
me sees you come in I'm going to stand
right here that's but I don't feel like
she's doing a good job acknowledging her
fears I used to sing for the Sisters in
the orphanage so they would know I was
all right it's like a very real fear
right but you know what this is just for
tonight she doesn't want people to walk
in and see her obviously she has trauma
Greg and you don't like Esther uh or she
takes on a true nightmarish form when
she sleeps oh this all has to do with
the ribbons she doesn't want anybody to
see what's under her
neck oh no what's behind
there Esther's the Devil Woman she
practices witchcraft or something what
is up with this child as a parent right
now do you open this or no oh absolutely
okay my brand new child I brought home
with this like Satan book yeah oh no
that's just about to come out oh no
who's in the photo maybe her dad oh no
all right Greg this shot this shot's
intense they tricked
me jokes on me did sound like she
stopped singing for a minute though if
this was like my child I've had for
years different story I just brought
this kid home I don't know what's in
this creepy book maybe you bring it to
her and ask I haven't opened it yet but
I would like to find someone dumb as oh
my God kids are so
mean I can't wait for you to die a
horrific death yeah he is killing me is
this a Bible Jesus Freak brought a bible
school
today oh
no your sister's a total spaz she's not
my sister oh no see you don't feel bad
for her Greg please I feel really bad
for her right now I do this your collar
little doggy oh my
God
whoa whoa that's a crazy shot and like
you know that little child actress had
to do that take 50 times with that
screen I think this movie does an
excellent job at having you go
something's up with this estra girl too
I feel so bad for this as girl it's
Mommy and Daddy on their wedding day
it's Daniel Christmas morning devil
child but she seems so happy to see the
family there's
you Esther joins who's Jessica I never
held you but I feel you you never spoke
but I hear you I never knew you but I
love you oh look at Esther she feels for
her what happened to her she died while
she was still in my tummy but we
scattered her ashes here so she had
ashes as as long as this plant grows and
part of her will be alive inside it oh
that's beautiful I didn't know PE do
people do that yeah but think about if
you killed the plant yes that is
bad started to open up today that's very
interesting yeah there's some
weird whoa whoa is it I this we
capturing the touches of their intimacy
kind of is creepy but she Esther's also
preventing their intimacy I think
oh
yeah yeah interrupt
eser it's cute though they're in love oh
oh she go for it she went from no no no
too actually let me just take my own
shirt off oh no we're going to see eser
ah oh I'm so nervous about this no no no
no no no no where is
esar Greg I'm trying to watch the movie
rocks where is Esther I have actually
really she's going to open her eyes and
see Esther for sure you think so
yeah Oh I thought I thought that was
moving oh my God that's so
creepy oh my God I mean you guys were
some irresponsible ass parents to be
doing that right in kit go to your room
we have to talk about last night do we
[Laughter]
I I would say that too I love it if
there's like nothing Supernatural it's
just like playing on the anxieties of
parenting Esther listen to
me when grown-ups love each other very
very much they want to show each other
that love they wouldn't express it I
know
they little Esther not that kind of
language around her she knew what it
meant and and babe the way she said it
is I don't even think she expected to
get in trouble over it well I'll talk to
her about it tonight Esther's been
exposed to some [__] remember she was
like I want to sleep next to Daddy so
that we can take her to Dr brownie I
don't think we need to take her to the
shrink quite yet well no she was only in
orphanage after her parents died in a
fire she shouldn't do therapy I don't
want her exerting that kind of influence
over man I just don't want to make a big
deal out of one little dirty word it's
not about how with your other it wasn't
just like he's she said the f word she
just said they I didn't even like use
that word in that context till much
later in my life look at your own
actions those parents why did you guys
do that cuz they love each other okay
they're Caucasian parents I'm going to
defend them at all costs Roxy I hope you
know this caucasian wealthy
parents hey haven't seen your R lately
uhoh I've been Prett oh no has the
homeowner association been soldiering on
without me it's not the
same he's cheating on his wife I think
so actually I had a favorite to ask um I
have a chair that I need moved upstairs
I was hoping you could come by and help
me sometime yeah sure maybe Kate and I
could help you out just let us know okay
I'll call you
uhhuh oh what's she going to do get to
worker oh
no ah [__] is going to get
pushed
oh no oh no Greg Greg Greg I like the
way this movie uses his settings a lot
feels like the thing that combat
cliches just as Greg Greg Greg
Greg nope Greg right now no no see soon
us a toy with your expectations Greg
Greg
Greg why didn't you escape to Mommy I go
up
now all right Greg we're still waiting
Greg Greg Greg smart how it plays on
like day-to-day anxieties on top of
everything
too I mean Esther has to dull out some
punishment little girl hasn't come she
was being a huge witch mhm mhm push her
face down
Esther wao
wo
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about this is
like Wednesday Adams so look right now
like if meline and Wednesday had a kid
it would beer sure yeah Brandon's father
says you pushed her that's not true we
were just playing I
swear eser okay and did you see what
happened Good Sister Good Sister man
it's not how it works between Greg and
jabby KO I snitch right away that my
little sister would do that for me a
heartbeat she slipped [__] I saw
nothing she
slip oh I hate that sound don't squeak
it don't squeak it can't even look at it
can you can you eat normal what do you
mean eat normal well my friends make fun
of me because of her maybe you needs
some different friends maybe you should
send her back to the re camp where she
belongs Daniel Daniel apologize to your
sister she's not
my sister that's where she got the f
word from or maybe that's where he got
it from okay that's
me he can't be a good husband he can't
be a I mean not not a good husband he
can't be a doesn't feel fulfilled as a
husband does feels like he's failing as
a father I mean they were just boning on
the counter but could he couldn't no he
couldn't finish man that was the first
time they were doing it in Forever get
the key back when you say you're sorry
oh I feel so bad for him that he
couldn't finish yeah man I would have
been like shiry
saw Greg ready for kids we're doing good
how is she she's right here hold on a
second Virgin Mary is watching I'm going
to need her medical dental charts for my
supervision
report she dropped the f bomb on me any
other glitches I should know of there a
girl named Brenda at
school damn you know your girl can read
lips right does she not know that no she
do does know she said that she keeps
those cular implants in so that she can
read limbs lips it helps her hear
enough you should have finished the job
Esther yes you and I are have two
different uh we are having two different
reactions to this Craig for sure oh my
God as is
[Music]
evolving you told me you didn't know how
to play no I didn't you offered to teach
me and I accept it that is true it must
be frustrating for someone who loves
music as much as you to have a son who
isn't interested in a daughter who can't
even
hear wait wait wait wait
wait oh man she is such a good actress
dude just like I try to be a good mom
but I'm getting frustrated you it's
hardly a lie huh you wouldn't know
honestly you wouldn't know she's always
always on her best behavior with you
she's I think Esther's trying to replace
her you think so my mind just went down
a really dark Twisted path but I think
that's what's happening I don't
know R Brenda trying doesn't like her
okay let's not blame her for anything
fine we'll take a word for everything
should I just believe what she said
about you and Joyce Patterson too what
did she say oh look at that nerv did she
invite you over she asked me to help her
move a chair I blew her off why didn't
you tell me because why we could have
laughed about it no I knew how hiding
honey I knew how you'd react he became
so laughing about it yeah his reaction
is big cheater energy it's only been 2
years since you told me know how sorry I
am I just feel like I a little trust
here big enery yeah okay and why did he
tell her two years ago we can talk about
my mistakes but not yours I was sick
you're an [__] who wanted to somebody
else put our child's life in D thought I
could walked months ago nobody would
have blamed me oh that's is sharp maybe
after her miscarriage she had some kind
of like psychotic with uh her other kid
that's why no nothing near the water
because he's saying she's saying I was
sick and he said put your her life in
danger it's like postpartum but you
didn't have the kid you know I don't
know just Theory may have made a mistake
I think there could be something wrong
with Esther that was the worst line of
dialogue in the movie after you told me
about the girl in The Playground I
called her old school there was a boy
who fell with a pair of scissors in his
hand and accidentally stabbed himself
through the
jaw most troubling thing is the Sullivan
house fire it was arson they have never
found the person who did it yeah little
devil mean lady here she's come to take
me away will you help me I love the way
they've written Esther I just love it I
think we need to know what we're dealing
with we're dealing with a 9-year-old
girl who's an orphan no that's it we're
taking her to Dr Browning we can take
take her to Dr Browning this is a
very generic horror movie plot that is
executed with a lot of nuance that I
really like most importantly casting
yeah like there's I'm surprised you
don't like him I think he is killing I
like I think he's good in this movie I
there's a lot of movies I don't like him
he's a really strong counter to her you
can see why they're together but you
could see where the problems would lie
yeah know they have good chemistry and I
I like the way how they the in between
with the miscarriage in between now is
how that's unraveling I think there's a
lot of really great quali oh my God you
smart cookie Smart Cookie no oh okay why
should she have to know how to do
[Music]
this why is she doing that do you want
to play Russian Roulette I'll call you
as soon as I find anything else out
right take care thank you very much
maybe
later this little girl is a good actress
man we'll scare her so bad she'll never
come back
here she plays her so realistic like
there's going to do shoot her tires
there's a sincerity to her wave your
arms and make her stop Max Go no oh my
God is she going to hit Max oh my God oh
my God oh my
God
wow
Esther Max
Max you okay finish the
job woo stop crying grab a foot and help
me get her off the road now what is she
I feel so bad for her though because
like this got to be a learned behavior
or something right she a little kid
she's nine Greg what is this stop crying
why does she know that's why I love how
they're portrayed normally it's like
Satan baby but why does she know piano
perfectly like it's based in some
psychology this is
[Music]
awesome Greg this is very upsetting this
is a very unsettling movie I'm loving it
she lives stay down stay down just don't
move bab that's what happens when the
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ is in your
life see
[Music]
oh the devil's coming to finish the
job oh my God I feel worse for Max
though me too because now Max like is
Max going to tell or no is that what
you're concerned about she said so the
trauma Max no but like if Max doesn't
tell her parents this girl stays around
you know she's got to tell but I'm
scared I'm sure she's scared help me
hide
her wow Esther you are horrifying she's
is a terrifying character yeah because
Greg I feel horrible for her this is
like some Stephen King [__] you think
she was born this way or do you think
she became came this way I think it's
best if we never find out but I would
suspect it's a well we got to know about
the ribbons we can't not know about the
ribbons the ribbons are the key to all
of this if you want to know my theory
it's that she tried to they'll send you
to un alive herself and she lived I had
to kill her because she was going to
tell on me you're not going to tell on
me are you say no say no do you think
she already spoke sign language and she
pretended she didn't or do you think she
just learned this quickly oh that's one
of the great questions of the movie
isn't it I think she already knew I
won't let anything happen to you I love
you I've seen creepy orphan characters
so many times I think this is an
amazingly different way of doing it
[Music]
oh no appear right before his eyes
what's the next shot is she come over or
no
yeah she's going to throw a rock or
something I don't
know oh no what she going to do in to
sleep no no no no
no this is what happened to her
night tell me what you saw
she's so good I saw you on maxos did you
tell anyone I didn't tell anyone if I
find out that you're lying I'll cut your
hairless little before you even figure
out what it's for is she like a Russian
spy she's like a an assassin maybe she's
really old and put herself in a little
body that's what I think I think she's
like a reincarnated Soul or something
like that or so like some like a Chucky
doll transfer but with a human well yeah
there's something to do with those
ribbons and her name being Esther it
seems she feels there's been some real
tension between the two of you she
really doing her best to please you but
you're blocking her attempts to bond
that's not true at all I I I've done
everything
right who's this this is Sister Judith
from St Maran really need to know if
Sister Abigail made it her appointment
with you Esther was watching yeah she
hasn't returned since
yesterday you got to find the body the
snow and the ice in this movie is really
smart choice too oh yeah helps create a
sense of isolation it's also hard to
know what's water below what's
[Music]
Frozen okay I think we're done no not
yet just don't understand this kind of
thing who would do this you know who you
know who I bet they arrest Vera figa or
something
[Music]
you and I are having two totally
different responses to this movie man
cuz I'm aware this movies also like just
wanted to be like a fun creepy child
movies on top of like psychological
trauma manifesting like what do you
believe about nature versus nurture
right I mainly believe in the nurture
triumphing over nature character disturb
children look at symptoms superficially
Charming difficulty making and keeping
friends good Googling they are adroit
manipulators often times playing people
off one another to get what they want
you going to show this to Dr brownie I'm
not showing her anything I'm not seeing
her anymore wow why does everyone around
here get the benefit of the doubt from
you except for
me I love Esther so much but do you I do
I love her so much what if Sister
Abigail was right I mean if someone was
in danger if our own children were in
danger our own children she doesn't
think of her as a child exactly I was
wondering if you'd heard from anyone at
the sudon orphan shelter in Russia
Sister Abigail had mentioned that she
would dude I would be having this
conversation like miles away from the
house I don't understand how can they
have no record of her being there yes
please could just call me as soon as
destroyed that [__]
Esther
there yes so I don't want to go to the
dentist but are you scared no we're
going to reschedule tell you what I'll
let you play hookie this morning if you
want to come downstairs and draw with me
but she has to get the dental records
how are you two uh getting along with
Esther has she ever made you feel I
uncomfortable or you done anything that
she's not supposed to do
no you got to tell how terrified your
kids are you got to tell kids are
usually better Liars than we give them
credit for but it's also like it's a
scary question so it's hard to read you
don't know how long I've waited for a
daddy just like you I don't think mommy
likes me very much why don't you do
something nice for mommy sh how much you
love her that's a wonderful idea what do
you got a p leave eser I have a special
surprise for you mommy you do pick these
flowers just for you
Esther wow they were the flowers from
the the dad child H she knew what these
roses meant to me my fault H my fault I
that's evil but you got to respect the
game you
know she is so
smart she going to hurt her own arm and
say it's from her mom I hope
so
oh my god oh my
god what have you done imagine breaking
your own arm Daddy see she wants to get
rid of mommy she wants to replace Mommy
I don't think it's replace her as much
as it's get rid of her my arms still
Hur got to call Child Protection
Services on
mommy sorry honey oh my God take her to
the hospital
doctor said you're going to heal real
fast
okay like I know that little [__]
isas you broke her arm it's impossible I
didn't grab her that hard she wants to
sleep in here tonight
oh Esther's the new mommy we got some
kind of Woody Allen situation going on
you know what I mean God you got to
chill with that
[Music]
bro
there it is she's back on the bottle
yeah cuz times are
bad yeah boy she's got to be wondering
her options like can we give her back or
does that make us the worst people alive
but if you give her back you don't get
your money back
right
ow oh my gosh man oh no oh no oh no oh
no
okay have a good day she's so smart cuz
she terrorizes you from
within know Daniel your books what
information have you left behind what
happened let me see your bag oh she got
a hole in the bottom we just bought this
pick it up it's going to get wet did
Esther plan on what Esther's driving I
should putting in the neutral oh with
their sister in the car mom
oh oh my god look how irresponsible you
are
[Music]
Mom oh my God this is a she's closing
her eyes oh my God he's going to hit the
snow
bank second time you've endangered your
child's life she didn't do it Greg I
know but this is switches this is what
the jury is going to say though I got
you here oh I'm saying I see what
Esther's plan is and you love her now
and I've te eser Max didn't indicate
that Esther did anything you are the
stupidest therapist I've ever seen man
Max is covering for her and I don't
think it's the first time it also
wouldn't be the first time you blamed
Esther for your own mistake okay well
that's fair the way Esther is getting
the
information girls found this this
morning there you go you mean Esther
found it yes Esther does it make any
difference is she lying you need help
we've reserved a place for you in a
rehabilitation facility about 45 minutes
from here
oh I didn't drink it we want to help you
but there's nothing we can do until you
stop lying to yourself I'm not lying to
anyone what happened this morning has
nothing to do with this whole footage
get cameras only reason that I'm sober
is because of Max and Daniel that is the
only reason where I would never do
anything to let something like that ever
happen again so
manipulative no I haven't given you
reason to believe me I love you this I
should have told you about this the way
the relationship is falling apart I'll
give you a week to go to reab or I'm
leaving and I'm taking the kids with
me wow oh should the mommy if
you you love her she's just so good at
the game I really thought we were
walking in like supernal Satan baby [__]
but the fact that it's not and this they
managed to make it believable enough I'm
just really impressed with the game if
you saw her you have to help me so Mom
and Dad can protect us keep your voice
down you don't need to talk loudly she
can't
speak that Sister Abigail stop talking
so loud you don't need to talk she can't
speak yeah but she can hear with the
thing and the lip reading I know but he
should can mouth it I know but he
doesn't need to talk so loud what did
she do in my
Treehouse are the bad things still there
no I'll get the stuff from The Treehouse
then they'll have to believe us oh my
God Idiot Boy you deserved
it clearly mommy will be on your side oh
no this is bad Greg tell the mom yeah
but what's she going to do find The
Treehouse stuff they're going to be like
you're drinking what I would do est's
going to get the Treehouse stuff
obviously I have to know about the
ribbons going somewhere kid she's like a
spy she's an assassin I will not let you
hurt my children I'm not the one who
passed out drunk and let Max almost
drown in the pond if it wasn't for John
you'd be dead M you'd probably still be
in jail who told you that it's very
intimate she was still kicking when the
doctor told me it was something called
Phantom's fetal movement nah 15 days I
carried my dead baby inside me it was
the crest torture I could imagine that
memory of hers we adopted her from you
how could you not know anything about
her the Sullivans could have adopted her
illegally oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
I don't want him to die I changed my
mind on that no cuz he's a a regular
[__] but so are big brothers at that
time
uh oh
noes she feel like she's always
watching Big thud what's in
it
it's all the dads it's all the dads oh
my God
Greg oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no Greg
Greg Greg is Esther up there and going
to push him because he's going for the
stuff or is the stuff just not there I
really don't know the answer to that
Roxy
I need to talk to somebody about uh one
of your children she is not come from
here well I haven't even told you her
name yet s Institute is not an orphanage
it is a mental
hospital this is bad news Greg this is
Bad News
Bears no no no
no do what you got to do
Esther are you looking for
this I couldn't have done it my myself
you know Max is just as guilty as I am
whatever Max did you made her do it it's
always better to burn the evidence oh
no what are you
doing are you crazy oh my
God let
me let me what do you do in that moment
if you're a little boy trapped in the
treehouse yeah exactly what he's
[Music]
doing it's called the S Institute you
irresponsible mom she's trying to help
all of her paperwork is from Russia I'm
sending them a picture of her right now
trying to find out whe maybe her birth
mother was a patient there what's that
Benjamin Button syndrome where you like
Dage oh it's real yeah I'm just saying
in movies it is
oh oh my
[Music]
God might still be
alive oh God call
[Music]
911 oh no she he's going to go beat him
you're going to
Happ yeah little Max let's go
[Applause]
Max move away move away from the fire I
love Max mommy's right here can you hear
me please wake up honey momy is right
here
okay something's wrong with us
that should be the name of the movie he
has a very serious neck injury he's
stabilized for now he's resting in the
ICU you got to believe the mom a tiny
bit at this point can I have a dollar
for the soda machine oh no your mother
wants you to stay right there what's
your plan there you go don't be too long
oh come on Grandma you got to know you
got to know something's wrong with that
girl she's going to kill what's his name
uh Daniel
Daniel wow the fact that she's going to
kill him right now
oh no Max knows Max tell the grandma go
save him again that's your
brother okay oh yeah just let her wander
the halls of the hospital by herself
grandma what the
f is he going to she going to put the
dollar in his mouth of course he wakes
up this point or
Daniel why is the machine not be he's
not getting enough oxygen oh she took it
off and put it on her finger smart girl
smart effing girl I know that's why I
you kind of rude for her how smart she
is what what is it
sweetie oh
[Music]
no oh code9 I see you he cardiac harest
stay out here Daniel all right here we
go go start a drip check TV please a
that's horrifying Dam this movie goes
aggressive with [__] huh okay oh no
don't do it don't do it don't do it what
are you do to you [__] dud you went too
to kill
my and she had the soda in her hand
[Music]
too okay well that's not something they
would do okay trying to prove she's
insane and then she's going to be the
one getting committed to the I no Miss
call what the Institute have to say we
need to know what the call was I hope we
find it in the post credit scene after
she's been Le bottomed don't worry about
Daniel he'll be okay you need to stay
overnight get some rest I'm going to
take Max and ner home oh wait where is
she in the hospital I think she's in a
different section of the hospital right
probably mental ward section or
something they wouldn't just let them
see her if she's just a mental ward
right there
because it's a movie
gr oh wow this is the time she needs to
tell her dad oh that's why she's
watching the dad does kind he is kind of
annoying me though like it he's got to
be a tad suspicious she took her clear
infant God he's got to be a little
suspicious it's a little
[Music]
frustrating yeah but she is showing him
who she wants him to be or she wants him
to think she is I
mean what's making you say that I think
my my I think my theory is gonna did you
see what she was wearing that was yeah
you think she like wants to date him I
think I said she wants to replace her by
being his wife or something I think it's
or something you know what I mean but
come on look what she's doing right now
I know I don't know what to make of it
Greg you got to have a more Twisted
mind
I think she's going to cut open
something nice for him hello Daddy there
it
is what are you wearing do you like
it oh she drugged his drink oh no I knew
this was going to happen but I didn't
want it to
happen
oh don't want to be alone I'm
scared I love you
Daddy you too oh my God I really love
you
oh my God great this is so
uncomfortable I can't stand you that you
had the same idea that these creators
did Sean let me take care of you what
are you doing you said you loved me I
don't love you like that oh no don't say
that you have to respect your mother I
do I just feel like I'm alone sometimes
in respecting you I don't think anyone
ever thinks about what you might be
feeling I really care about you John oh
my God go John I'm just I'm tired oh my
God she's doing it very tired this movie
know I'm sick this is so
uncomfortable oh no why did you do this
gray I had no idea that didn't they
would go this far man you said it from
the top and I thought you were
insane stop talking and go upstairs go
to your room stop talking to me like I'm
a child I'm calling sister Judith
tomorrow we're going to have a
conversation about your future in this
house I can't do it uhoh don't say that
too far you went too far sir the last my
name is Dr vava I'm calling from the SAR
Institute the nick of time call I've
just seen the picture you emailed to us
and do you recognize her where is she
right now there is that disease where
people don't look older they get to like
35 the little girl in the picture is not
really a little girl she's a grown woman
yeah doesn't grow up She has a rare
hormone disorder it's called
hypopituitarism she only looks like a
child Lena clamber was born in
1976 she's 33 years old yeah when she
was here she was kept in a straight
jacket to stop her from hurting our
stuff but she was constantly fighting to
get out of it it got into her skin and
left her with scars around her wrists
and neck got it she's dangerous there
violent she killed seven people that we
know of see her true form she's been
passing herself off as a little girl for
most of her life she said how can she
fool us she didn't fool you when she
couldn't seduce the father she killed
him and his whole family then she burned
the house down yeah this is so funny if
it's really anina you don't have much
time she just got up and was like
this that Nick of Time movie at least
she can't go to Child Protective
Services like at least she HD an adult
so purge yeah okay
oh my God they're gone and she knows it
uh do you think he's going to cheat on
his wife now do I think he's going to
cheat on his wife yeah now that he knows
now that she's 33 Greg I want you to
stop making predictions because I T to
come true and that will throw me off of
a balcony can you imagine if that's
this oh we found the paint the
glow-in-the dark NightLight yeah man
watch your house burn look at your burnt
house this a little girl is a freak and
not a little girl there's that real life
story of a girl who has this disease
where she looks like 12 and she's dating
a 50-year-old or
whatever oh
no the
[Music]
truth oh so she did the artwork for the
Su The Suicide Squad movie from David oh
my god of her touching him ew ew oh no
Daddy's dead yeah but he drugged she
drugged him I think oh my
God protect your daughter and she has
the gun remember I feel like Esther's
going to come out on top remember she
has the gun yeah I did till I said it no
I forgot but you reminded me and my fear
has been enhanced now dude I hope estra
wins what is wrong with you
Greg oh
no oh
[Music]
no oh my God she looks older now
oh oh he's way
dead but why is she driving like
this where's Max going to go oh she
wants her ear
[Music]
things hide in the
closet
oh no come on you're going to ruin the
equity on the
house it's just like why didn't she stop
sooner like it doesn't take you quicker
she just freaked out I get it I mean I
don't get it but oh my god oh
no no no this is a tragic ass movie
isn't it go find Max
damn oh God like
at least she knows in this moment that
he didn't hook up with the kid you got
to find the Silver Linings in dark
times why would you fall for Esther's
trap come on you got to know oh
no why would you fall for Esther's
trap did it hit
her what she going to shoot Max oh no
don't shoot
Max it sucks because Max doesn't know
how loud she's being that's one part
about like they can feel vibrations in
certain things and you
[Music]
know oh my God but you got to go save
[Laughter]
Max she locked the door the window
Esther you little
genius oh and she doesn't know she broke
that that's what I'm
saying oh no oh no
no no no no Greg you'll be fine
Roxy oh my
God
new fall on her fall on her is that the
solution dude Esther's a good shot stop
go you
[Music]
harder go down
there
yep yep that was the only move yep oh
Max's going to take the
gun oh Max take the gun no you got to
put one final bullet in Esther's head
you got to make sure Esther's dead
oh what a mom will do for her
kids
oh why didn't you make sure estra was
dead because there needs to be a sequel
Greg the orphan Strikes
Back Revenge of the orphan interesting
move to then do this what bu Max in the
sow take Max to the woods cops are going
to show up cops are are going to be like
and I think she did it yeah Esther's not
going to be
there yeah but she has proof now that
this was
a
St gunshot
gunshot
gun oh Max is going to have to shoot
her oh not the water ouch oh good you
can overcome your
trauma Max get the gun oh they're going
to go in she's going to fall in come on
what is Max going to do with this gun I
think Max is gonna team up with Esther
and shoot the mom or she's
[Applause]
gonna oh the ice
Falls
OH ver fora really doesn't deserve to
die oh no oh no is everyone going to die
Greg that would be
crazy
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no cig oh no
it's too dangerous go back oh
no
oh this goddamn Devil
Woman don't let me die
mommy she's got the knife yeah I'm
not Mommy
knife
[Music]
ooh oh no get off the ice get off the
ice get off the
ice it's it's not over Greg it's not
there's a sequel always the orphan
always the orphan never the bride they
should do an orphan for called orphan
forever huh two two orphan two for
serious
two yeah what that's kind
[Music]
of oh my God this movie over what the
hell yo Max you got a weird service what
the this [__] just happened
here we got to see if there's a post
credit scene nail polish DiCaprio
produced
that's the only thing I heard about this
movie for years is that what was that
Leonard Di Caprio produced this movie I
didn't know Vera fora and Peter Sor in
this movie till moments before we filmed
this movie how did you find out then
because uh I saw it when I was loading
this that what they
were John alond yeah good
score it's waited out Roxy waited out
wait it out not enough Margo
Martell
no this made you like Peter
better he's all
right there's just something about him
that just I don't know what it is
personal Vendetta I I can't quite
pinpoint it
I get like he's just always kind of
irritating me I don't know what it is
you don't have that with any actor you
don't have to name them yeah I do Anne
hathway Ann hathway just kind of gets
under your skin I kind of feel bad about
it too cuz she's so good that's how I
feel about Peter sarsgard like he's
really good there's something about him
that really irritates me yeah but I feel
bad too cuz like that's not nice I'm
sure annaway is lovely I know I think
she's great but I think a lot a lot of
people feel that way about a lot of
people do just irks me sometimes did I
get it all right with
music all
right hey guys listen if you were
listening to us on Apple or Spotify we
just watched orphan I'm joined with Roxy
strier who is in a great mood I can tell
look at this Joy I see you did this to
me suting off of her face this was the
craziest part of the whole movie you
obviously wrote it I didn't I knew
exactly how this was gonna play out
which is the craziest part because you
wrote this movie and then you made me
watch it and pretended like that's not
what happened I mean i' I've seen so
many psychological horror dramas that
the second it was like bottle I just
couldn't believe that you knew they were
she was trying to hook up with it it was
pretty obvious not to me bro because my
mind doesn't go there it was PR I I
thought it was more creepy when I think
the movie played it a little
safe with 33y
old I I felt like it it
got okay hold on a second can you scooch
over to your left a little
bit is it cuz you were about to say some
pet no the frame's not
good we are not Cent framed here I'm
going to slightly scoot you in here but
you told me to go left I know but you
moved too far
left Roxy please is there's no time to
Ru with the great Greg Alba it is 2024
now oh you did write this famous movie I
did write it okay what I gonna say oh
yeah see this over
there the H&M bag no no no in the Box
here no that to be installed here is a
spot for the keyboard M I can't see cuz
I know you're going to be like uh what
did
made uh who did did you
and I'm going to have to be
like
[Music]
okay do you hate
me I bring you
here do you despise me treat you bad but
I am about to do that to you so like I'm
telling you we need to look up if any
part are we really for sure doing this
okay we got to know well then I'm not
going to attach
it yeah but what about okay the very
minimal I could put this on my lap yeah
I know it's for me it's for me uh it's
for me I have this you don't know how to
like yeah but I have this keyboard yeah
you're not the best no well we'll see I
Am Woman so how do I
keyboard and unfortunately I actually am
not the best of this I have a feeling
okay so what's what are we looking up
what are we're looking up guys if you're
listening to Apple and Spotify Roxy is
currently looking for
a web browser on the computer and she
doesn't realize we are currently already
on a web
browser the web browser is right on
screen okay no that's good that's good
okay not now not now okay so is the
orphan based on a true story okay
spelled a few things wrong there but
while whilst looking at the keyboard
typing but yeah we could ignore because
I can't I'm blind as a bat so I can't
see that far and this keyboard is weird
yeah it's the keyboard was big okay so
the orphan is B I'll read it for you
since you can't read and um you don't
know how to zoom in I'm assuming do you
know zoom in it's not it works uh the
movie Orphan it's like it's command oh
yeah yeah you learned it you learned it
you did it um the movie Orphan is based
on a true story about bar bar Bora
Barbara Barbara Barbara scova who posed
a 12-year-old girl named Anika in the
Czech Republic barbora Barbara lies and
manipulation led to her being taken in
by a woman named Clara who subjected her
own children to horrific
abuse okay but it wasn't like this story
it's Inspire it no I'm saying look at
her that's okay that's that's crazy
that's crazy yeah she literally looks 12
um that's a crazy story so wait a minute
but thenone all this [__] didn't go down
though like they they
totally real life
story
Greg how wait how true is this I I don't
know are we about to have our minds
blown right blows my mind that this even
like any part of this I mean I could
totally believe that someone with this
condition would pull some [__] okay okay
I didn't realize it's true cuz I thought
the movie was kind of chickening out on
me have you ever seen the orphan or it's
prequel orphan first don't Ru don't ruin
orphan first kill okay but it's we might
want to watch we might want to watch you
haven't considered this some major
spoiler territory orphan toy for which
one I don't know Craig I haven't read
the article have you seen if you
haven't okay all right okay I think we
can read it go
ahead let's read the real story uh okay
Barbara scroll down a little more scroll
okay stop
stop okay Barbara was born with hypo
to claraa in the Czech Republic her
story about being a 12-year-old girl
named anakah certainly seemed plausible
asard her story about fleeing from a
violent group home the single mother of
of two took Barbara uh anakah home POS
Anica where she lived with her children
and her sister Katrina she treated her
like a family right away with the
intention of adopting her Anica claim to
be extremely sick requireing multiple
doctor appointments but curiously would
only allow Kina to take her as it turned
out the pair were involved in a cult
called The Grail movement this is
crazier a group that follows the
teachings of a 19th century Mystic from
Germany and Barbara's father was head of
the Czech branch of the movement at the
time wow this is like a totally
different story to keep up the charade
Katrina wrote notes about anaka
so-called treatment acting as her doctor
over time Barbara persuaded claraa that
her problems were all due to her two
children that they should be abused and
they were most terrifically okay wow
okay look before we I don't think we
need to dive into we we we could do a
whole video about this some other time
cuz yeah this gets like really I I'm
just saying it you didn't know and I
brought value today you did that you
brought a lot of value because that is
crazier and actually worse from what I
previewed that's wild yeah this although
it doesn't seem like any of the sexual
stuff went down uh some other stuff did
according to what I previewed
what some other stuff did what I
previewed no what I previewed on the
article involving the brothers like in
your eyes just now without reading out
loud yeah I quickly skined some of the
Bots this I was like we shouldn't touch
on this right now oh oh oh yeah because
it looks like it gets worse than what
happens in the
movie dang it I thought the movie was
chickening out by making her a 33y old I
was more like bull move movie well I I
was having this and this is off topic on
topic like this conversation the other
day so say she wasn't a serial killer
right say she was just a 33-year-old who
looked like that so this really happens
to people in real life and then they
grow up and they look like kids and then
they Lucy Hae and no not like Lucy Hae
like this real thing and they get
married to I can pull up the girl she
looks about 12 but she is in her late
20s and she is with this guy who's in
his late 30s and it's like that like is
that pedo Behavior to be with somebody
who looks like a
child um not if you know they're not a
child but like why are you attracted to
them because of who they are I don't
know that's what people I'm not I don't
know how to put that's
why I know so I'm saying not that I feel
bad for Esther but Esther probably wants
to have like a life and can't because
nobody looks at her like an adult you
can't be murdering people no bottom line
in this movie I'm not talking about real
life yeah all right we'll talk about the
movie I'm talking about the movie I'm
saying like you this orphan girl clearly
was messed up definitely clearly Esther
had problems I told you was an older
person name um but she you did help me
that you and I both believe more in
nurture versus nurture than nature which
means that probably she had a really
messed up life before she did this but
now you're 33 so you have to do better
so you hate her and I'm really glad they
made her 33 I didn't think it was a cop
out at all because I felt bad for her
because she was a child and then I had
zero remorse or bad feelings for her
because she's an adult see it relieves
your yes my guilt your feeling yep
exactly and I but I but I I kind of like
I feel like if this was some independent
movie they would have kept her as a kid
no just to just if it was like anaer a24
that's so much just to drive exactly to
drive over the creepiness of it and to
drive home the the horrific side cuz it
it it removed some of it's weird like I
I would surpris based on a true story
I'm not surprised based on a true story
I'm saying like like hearing there's a
true thing that happened would surprised
me about I know you want to say
something what do you want to say no I
don't no as you did the thing you I
heard the breath come out and you you
put your hand over your mouth and I was
like she wants to say something and then
I was just listening to then I found
myself being like this is rude I should
let her talk
what
yeah no I had I was just listening to
what you were saying because it's what
were we saying what was I saying I don't
remember what I was saying you were
talking about them alleviating us and if
it was a 824 movie and then you were
going into something else about that
yeah I don't know uh I I mean because
like okay the like the the true story
they were saying I'm like that sounds
like a movie in it of itself because
normally you hear the true story and
it's and it and it's dialed back like
the true story is usually not as bad
yeah and and and the true story is veers
off in a completely different direction
but is also I could see the foundation
being similar enough whereas this they
took the horror movie tale that we've
heard before like
um uh God it is hard for me to think of
some titles right now cuz sometimes it's
not sometimes just like orphans orphans
are biological kid who's born he's like
Satan child or something right like what
was that movie um that it wasn't
Superman but it was gone breit bur or
something breit bur yeah yeah I mean
like that it's kind of a it's it's a
horror movie Trope of like creepy child
we have in our home you know yeah there
you go you figured it out you figured
out how to use the internet I know
computer good so um what are we looking
up I'm going to look up movies with
orphans to help you no thanks movies
with orphans yeah that's literally
movies with orphans I thought that'd be
helpful I mean he maybe specified a
little bit like no like horror movies
orph kids hug Hugo is
not yeah oh shley Temple sto away I love
that movie you were just looking up
movies with orphans these are not like
horror movies Oliver Oliver never before
has a boy wanted more creepy horror
movie children all mine to give type in
creepy horror movie children okay seems
like a different thing Megan it's not
it's actually way more in tune with what
we are actually talking about than
looking up random movies with orphans
that's what you had said you said
there's a lot of Orphans yeah I'm
talking about the Trope of of like
horror movie
children it's weird that when you wrote
this movie you didn't look this up
already of course not children of the
cor corn
um hide and seek and
uh Village of the children kid reminded
me of her actually in some ways yeah
which I just saw for the first time
there was one with Sam Rockwell where
they have like creepy I'm I'm I'm used
to it being like Satan baby stuff look
bottom line look uh the this the
story CL it's not CL Joshua is what it
is spooky child terrorizes family movie
It's called
Joshua
um fre get so caught up and other things
I'm not getting I'm listening to you I
was helping make your point I'm
distracted oh no what did you think of
the movie is ver formiga in that one too
with Sam Rockwell you want me to go look
it up I got to know now [__] man what
you what have you done just go to
history go to the history I can't see
where it says history go scroll to the
very top go to Top Bar go where it says
history I can't see it one to the left
one to the yeah there you go and then go
to Joshua right there the very top top
one yeah yeah yeah you can read those
words yeah I can I have glasses on crazy
oh she is in that movie about Creepy
child you got to be kidding me this is
her this is her genre okay she's very
good and Sam Rockwell is very good yeah
I should watch this movie yeah damn
that's that's wild oh I did want to see
this little girl that plays what we will
talk about the movie I want to see the
little girl that plays God damn it with
this mouse the little girl that
plays what the [__] was this movie
called Megan what is this movie Orphan
orphan orphan yeah you're out there you
Orab Oh I thought it was the orphan it's
just orphan yeah it's just orphan oh I
made that point at the beginning you the
third one's going to call be called The
Orphan so who is this actress she was
Stellar I know it would it be weird to
then go see her in some kind of high
school like CW type
show cuz I mean she's she's she'd be a
kid uh okay
Isabella oh she's like a full-blown
adult now this was in
2009 okay she was she was in orphan at
the age of 10 damn she was 10 years old
and doing that she's very good I thought
she was like 14 15 damn to see her in a
lot of other things um oh Hunger Games
she was clove interesting I don't
remember that that's very impressive
yeah very impressive very impressive
stuff very impressive I don't think do
you think it was impressive I think it
was impressive I feel like if there one
we could say very thought the movie was
good I did yeah uh it be like they took
it was like the structure became
insanely predictable like right away
once we found out you no me you got it
too like once it was like okay once it
was recovering alcoholic and and or or
someone who was like uh who who could go
down the bottle again and they're going
to adopt overcoming trauma of the
miscarriage it was like okay they're
going to adopt the child and then creepy
things are going to be happening and
then uh once things are going bad for
them
no's along the Journey of having creepy
child she's going to pick bottle again p
on the mom and very early on it was like
okay yeah then she's going to try to
seduce the death that I didn't pick up
on I never thought she was going to try
to seduce that it was going down I
wasn't sure because it was a it was a
Warner Brothers movie that like would
they do that I thought she was going to
try to get rid of the mom because she
just didn't want she just wanted to have
the dad I did not know about the
seduction part that was like I just
refused to believe it the whole time
despite the evidence once I started
realizing it was a psychological film
and not a super natural one cuz I wasn't
sure if it was going to be like
Supernatural kid horror cuz that's
usually what they do with the kid ones
is like they're kid whor I'm not kid
whor they're uh Supernatural horres and
yeah no I said the sentence
right we this is the first time we
filmed together on a Saturday afternoon
and now now you're understanding why
know y this is this is Greg on a
Saturday afternoon um so the God damn it
I I keep losing my time supernatural
horror no I said that right yeah yeah
that's right um yeah once I realized
that that then suddenly some stuff
started becoming a little bit um Prett
in terms of plot
mechanics but but I what I loved about
it was the attention to detail on the
nuances of H of what was going on with
these characters like having history
with what occurred between the parents
and between the miscarriage and and the
and then the actual adoption and also
the gray area to of the grief of the
miscarriage like that's not something
you often see in movies of mourning the
loss of that life you know so you feel
like even though it did play on a lot of
horror tropes just having those few
twists made it stand out and be unique
yeah I mean like structurally it fall if
you write down to the freak and she gets
the call at the nick of time and the
finale to get the big reveal about who
Esther really is like there there's a
lot that they did that felt that way but
they like even with the sexuality with
the par with watching words here but
even being a lot of movies will shy away
from the sexuality of the parents and
and and uh and her on the counter yeah
yeah damn took her on the counter oh
well those are words that you won't get
Flagg for yeah it's true uh but no like
a scene like that where they actually
went um really mature about it in
graphic and I'm kind of used to
Hollywood putting a gloss over this
where this had a little bit more of a
grit that I like to see from a Warner
Brothers produced film if that makes
sense like a studio made movie I mean it
was actually challenging to watch at
times because of that and I think that
if it hadn't been then it wouldn't have
had the same effect on us and we
wouldn't have thought it was as powerful
of a movie it also killed the dad and
debatably killed the son so no yeah I
know he's alive well we don't know he
was alive they said he was alive they
said to him he the dad said to Mom you
have a glitter or
snot really snot s you have something on
your nose is it the cracker I gave you
earlier how long has it been there I
don't know I don't think he's you can
see it on camera is it glitter or it's
not it's definitely G now I don't know
what it was oh it's like a white spot I
see it is it a cracker it looks like
paint why would you have paint on your
ey I don't know oh but that is what it
looks like right they have Roxy a
cracker earlier po a cracker let's see
if they can
see yeah does look I thought it was a
snot spot was like oh man maybe I should
have told her about
this bet her all time I was just like
don't say anything you'll embarrass her
if you say something you knew it was
there the whole time no I didn't until
right now should I put it back on my
nose like what do I do with this
paint huh interesting I don't know how I
got there no me neither I hope it was
there from the very beginning and people
were questioning it yeah and that they
didn't make it through to the end of the
video okay watch because it's freaking
snot was on this girl's face the whole
time every time we cropped in on her um
anyway good job with the movie so look
we got we got I think I think we get
eight more minutes in here and then
we're good to go so Roxy give some
opinions uh okay think that the acting
was like essential in this movie to make
it good oh we were just talking about
the sun I don't know I don't feel
confident the sun lived because remember
when the dad came into the room and said
to her he's going to be fine don't worry
I didn't know whether he's just
appeasing her cuz she's in the hospital
because what we know is that they said
he if we don't go in there he'll go into
cardiac AR
and then they said that he was stable
for a second but they got a pulse they
had a pulse his neck was broken they
said before that they didn't even know
if he was going to be able to ever
answer the questions so it depends what
you mean by like f like he might be in a
vegetative state so just my mind was
dark the reason I'm saying it is because
this movie was willing to kill one of
its major characters and highly injure
if not kill the other along with injure
another child like it really did go
there with the injuries and the death
and uh that's why at the end with Vera
Fig's character and with and they killed
the orphan too that's why I thought it
was so bold too oh yeah yeah because you
we don't know and so the the stakes are
high because you don't know who's going
to die I wouldn't have been surprised if
at the end the little girl died you know
because it's like this movie was willing
to so genuinely when the little girl's
out on the ice and Vera Fara is saying
go back go back I'm like oh my God are
they about to kill off this the youngest
child and I I I really like that about
the movie because while I was I wasn't
as con I was convinced that
like Esther's not actually no you know
what I'm not sure there was like only it
was only until like moments before
Esther finally descends to the ice where
I was like okay Esther's going to lose
it was only like a few moments before we
don't even know that Esther dies though
that's true uh be ice creature uh which
I could totally believe and I think that
for most of the movie I was here going
you know what Esther could Esther could
walk out on top yeah and everybody else
could die yeah Esther could totally win
uh like I felt like it became the most
movie in the last 15 it was after the
may the Lord Jesus bless you uh it was
it was after the reveal of 33-year-old
Esther when when it started feeling the
most like I'm watching a movie now yeah
I get that well there was a couple lines
that I was like ah the movie wrote a a a
a good line of it always felt like a
movie that's why I always found it like
fun because it was doing this thing
where it was feeling like okay it's
psychological trauma we're dealing with
real diseases and real types of
manipulation forms and okay we're
exploring how children can also be
little sociopaths and the anxieties of
grief they were doing all these
qualities that were they were thrusted
all to the performances and then all the
stuff about the affairs and trying to
amend a relationship and how to be a
parent and the and the consequences that
came from not taking care of yourself
like they were doing all these things
that I thought help make it feel more
rich and alive and that people can lie
to their therapists and trick them
exactly like cuz normally these movies
are like a 90 minute and just 90 minutes
of just kids standing around creepily
and and and long drawn out shots that
they sell as tension with some slick
cool visuals is usually what these
movies are
and I felt like what they did was they
they did a great job on selling you on
the family drama the wonder when they're
first adopting even like making Esther
an appealing child to adopt like out of
the kids you're like damn I would want
the smart one why wouldn't you want the
smart one that was interesting from jump
that she stayed upstairs though and
didn't come down to the party and that
he just stumbled upon them because it's
like that's pure luck I mean she lured
him kind of she 100% lurt she was
watching from the outside she was going
to the bathroom though like and she she
was planning it yeah she was but the
fact that he did that it was lucky that
she he wanted to go inside and go to the
bathroom yeah but I mean a lot of what
Esther does is like based off of like
luck she's like the Final Destination
death character that's why we liked it
so that's why we liked it because this
girl plays the domino effect I got to
tell you this makes me feel really
powerful what that I love this thing
this makes me feel buckled in and like I
could tell you anything Gul had to offer
that's it's is bought to and it's meant
to be there not attached to this thingy
in front of us that the audience can't
see really yeah it's meant to be
attached to that yeah well I like it
here because I feel like I could tell
you all about the oran I could tell you
up down Center yeah you look also really
comfortable you don't look trapped you
don't look like a child feel trapped you
don't look like a child at a booster
seat do I look the same age as Esther or
you don't look like a super villain
who's locked in some type of weird cage
right
now Esther's actually my best friend uh
do you like uh Peter
sarsgard I did like him I thought he was
a really good counter to Vera figga
although frustrating at times like oh
how could you not see this I kind of
understood you know he adopted a child
and his wife has a history of these
things so it's he has reason to doubt I
thought he did a really good job in this
I thought the kids were really
impressive too like often times I think
that the child actors just bring you out
especially when we're dealing with
people of the caliber of like Vera figga
um again I know that she was only in a
small part but Marco marale like when
we're dealing with these Oscar Emmy
winning worthy people to have the kids
be I'm super invested in them and their
performances it's even the max I thought
she was so good but all three of the
kids really really good job well usually
usually in these films like it's one
parent even if it's like there's a
haunting in the house that or something
that like the dad it's hating of Hill
House no no not that that's like way too
good that's way too deep and amazing uh
talking about more of the cliche ones
like there's one with like Katie Holmes
I believe um there that's like either
the D Katy Holmes and Guy Pierce what
the hell is that movie called and
there's and there's uh it's the Trope
usually goes it's either the they think
the dad's crazy but he's not or they
think the mom's crazy and she's not so
this movie went with the of oh they
think the mom's crazy but she's not and
for a m and the reason why it became
frustrating for me with the dad was
because the movie was doing such a good
job at having conversations and a new
that's what it's called Don't Be Afraid
of the Dark the movie was doing such a
good job at having conversations and
nuances and further debates about Stu
like the way they fleshed out stuff like
okay we're doing the Trope of like uh
everyone thinks the mom's crazy but we
as the audience no she's not crazy but
the way they were going about it with
exploring it and the dialogue I was like
it makes a lot of sense why they think
the mom's like crazy yeah because of
what happened the last time because of
the finding the bottle and because of
her in the therapy sessions they did a
good job with that what I wasn't finding
believable with the dad was I like I
would get to a I think I think it
reached a certain point there was a
there was a whole point where I was 100%
feeling exactly what you were saying and
maybe it was like at I don't know
somewhere around like the 80 minute Mark
I suppose like when they're in the IC
with her son in the freaking treeh house
is on fire and they're learning this
information about look I was looking
into her past and we can't find this
thing you you I feel like the dad at a
certain point had to be like maybe there
is something up with this Esther CH even
if he just believes it's a child maybe
there's something up with this child and
you do have to start to wonder
like I think there had to have been a
little bit of a gray area with the dad
of him going she's not my child like we
did just adopt her you know one of the
things that I was curious about because
they made that choice for the Treehouse
is burning that they had the mom his mom
be there for that sure uh so I was like
huh that's interesting because if his
mom hadn't been there I thought maybe he
would believe that Vera Fig's character
actually on accident started the fire
and that would be reason to once again
not pin this on Esther exactly but when
she says your mom was there this time I
was like oh yeah so really what is his
excuse this time finally to be like it's
still not Esther cuz when she says it
was either Esther or
Daniel like exactly and he's and she
says which one was it he said I don't
know but at the same time it is a child
that you're dealing with and she Vera
figa character is almost too quick to
pin it on her so it's both
extremes that's fair that's fair I I
mean overall I think the I mean like the
acting helps save so much of it I love
the use of environments the way they
utilize like the house the playgrounds
um the overall setting of you understood
the distance of every where they were at
like the they the way they played what I
really liked is like they fleshed out a
lot of familiarity in a way that was
really impressive to me it's like the
bottom line of it with um with and it
felt more adult and mature when I think
a lot of times they would try to make
this more PG-13 and and I I appreciate
the way they didn't shy away from like
the violence hits it was R-rated right
oh a th% man there's no way you get away
with like
they said the f bomb that's the
sexuality and the uh and the violence it
really hits yeah yeah I agree yeah and I
appreciated the the maturity of that
because even for a lot of our way to
horror movies from Studio films they
it'll still feel like glossy I prach the
maturity of us we're very mature we're
very very mature very mature just like
we talked about your snot cracker yeah
well I I have a keyboard because I'm
mature yeah oh no what I do what have
you done I don't know
Al righty well is there okay one last
thing to look up I promise um can you
just look up uh Jamie Colette Sarah and
like I want to know if he directed that
shark movie what shark movie yeah right
there just go down you're not talking
about 47 meters down are you no no no
I'm talking about the shallows yeah
right there the
shallows the shallows that's a good
movie you haven't seen it no oh that's
good I like Blake oh I wonder if Terra
seen it that'd be a good one to put you
on for in the sh
shall if we have recommendations for it
of course in the sh shall you haven't
seen that one it's really good no and I
like her she doesn't have a good Boston
accent but I do like her I thought I
about to say body and I was like wow why
would I say that cuz you said it doesn't
have a good ba andent and then my the
time froze for me and I didn't let you
she doesn't have a good body and said
B The Flash right there like what she to
say they're like 10 body perfect perfect
all bodies are perfect Greg I would
never okay but what if someone looks 12
when they're really 33 is that a perfect
body I wouldn't be attracted to them
because I think that that's weird but I
do feel bad for them they deserve love
but I just could never be attracted no
matter what their mind was if you look
12 I'm not attracted to
you like Lucy
hail do you know who Lucy hail is I know
who Lucy Hae is I do I want you to look
at her and you tell me that you think
she looks 12 if you were to tell me
she's playing a 12-year-old I would be
like I see it like what are you talking
about
okay I mean yeah she's she's cool she's
like a full-blown adult I know she's
really
famous really famous for a 12-year-old I
mean she look 12 there she doesn't look
12 anywhere 12-year-old she dressed like
that God what that's very inappropriate
for a 12-year-old drling in what way
does she look
12 okay Greg get us out of here all
right guys well how old do you think
Lucy hail looks audience leave your
thoughts down below is or from first
kill worth watching would you adopt if
you started adopting and then they
started doing [__] like this would you
kick them to the curb would you try to
get a refund leave your thoughts Down
Below guys I'm Roxy
I'm Greg Alba and we are the real
rejects peace
[Music]
out